the White House says President Trump
supports the massive spending bill
unveiled by congressional leaders
lawmakers have until midnight tomorrow
to pass the bill to avoid a government
shutdown its 1.3 trillion dollars will
fund the government through September
the president slammed Democrats in a
tweet saying quote had to waste money on
dem giveaways Julianna Goldman is on
Capitol Hill Julianna good morning good
morning well that's right yesterday the
president's aides said mr. Trump
supports the bill and that was after
House Speaker Paul Ryan went to the
White House and briefed him on the
details the measure would provide 1.6
billion dollars to fund the president's
border wall but that's first sort of the
25 billion dollars that the White House
has sought now on guns the bill also
includes the so-called fix Nick's
legislation which improves the sharing
of mental health and criminal record
information and gun background checks
that's backed by the NRA so in return
Democrats got a provision that makes
clear that the government can use
federal funds through the Centers for
Disease Control to research gun violence
now the bill also does not include
protections for so-called dreamers and
for that the president blamed the
Democrats saying that they just didn't
care the bill also provides funding for
the opioid crisis and increases defense
spending Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer called it a very good compromise
Gale the house is set to vote later this
afternoon before sending it to the
Senate okay thank you Julianna